some people think hospitals are the most
dangerous places on Earth more people
die inside them than anywhere else when
people say things like that they are
technically right and may get fooled by
what's known as selection bias
[Music]
a selection bias occurs when we look at
information that is not fully
representative of the data intended to
be studied as a result of the biased
sample we then draw a false conclusion
one story that explains the bias perhaps
better than any other is that of Abraham
Wald Wald was a brilliant mathematician
who after the Nazis persecuted him and
his family as Jews in Austria fled to
the United States in 1938
during World War II world was invited to
become a member of the statistical
research group an elite Think Tank to
Aid the American war effort against Nazi
Germany one day the U.S Air Force came
to Wald and his colleagues with a
problem many of their planes got shot
down due to a lack of armor
the officers presented walled with data
for all the aircraft that made it back
from their mission the planes had lots
of holes on the body and wings but less
below the engines
the officers then asked the
mathematicians to compute the optimal
protection by concentrating the armor
where the planes were getting hit the
most
after studying the problem Walt
suggested something unexpected the armor
he said doesn't go where the bullet
holes are it goes where the bullet holes
aren't
[Music]
the officers didn't understand because
they were looking at a biased sample
world wasn't he realized that to get
representative data to analyze he needed
to include the missing holes the missing
planes the missing information
the reason planes were coming back with
fewer hits to the engine is that planes
that got hit in the engine weren't
coming back he explained but selection
bias isn't just the result of missing
information
the Simpson Paradox is a phenomenon in
which a trend appears in groups of data
but then when the groups are combined
disappears it shows the importance of
really understanding the data we select
for analysis hmm
one famous example came from students
applying to the University of California
Berkeley in 1973. the data showed that
males applying were more likely to be
accepted than females people thought
that the institution was discriminating
against women
when researchers dug deeper into the
data they found out that men had applied
to less competitive departments with
higher rates of admission women chose
more competitive departments with fewer
available spots after correcting for
this detail the data showed a
significant bias in favor of women not
men
planes that were shot in the engines
were not analyzed women in Berkeley
weren't discriminated against but
instead picked more competitive classes
people that die in hospitals are often
already sick when they are admitted
what are your thoughts is selection bias
corrupting your decision making and if
it's fooling you how about the people
behind the research you see being
published in popular media did they
really make sure they selected an
unbiased fully representative sample
share your thoughts in the comments
below and if you still don't quite
understand it here is a simple challenge
to experience it firsthand
go out of your house knock at the doors
of your next 10 neighbors and ask those
who open if they are afraid of strangers
after you are done report your findings
in the comments below and explain to us
what can your research tell us about
your community anything
[Music]
this video was brought to you by
brilliant.org
brilliant is a learning platform we
really like because it's playful
interactive and perhaps the best way to
learn maths in computer science
brilliant challenges you with problems
that you then have to solve
interactively
an approach that allows you to master
complex Concepts in 15 minutes a day
whether it's introduction to probability
applied probability statistics or random
variables when it comes to mathematical
thinking brilliant has all sorts of
simulations for you
'll learn how to think in numbers
relationships stats and distributions
all essential skills for life
to try everything brilliant has to offer
free for a full 30 days visit
brilliant.org Sprouts or click on the
link in the description the first 200 of
you will get 20 percent of brilliant's
annual premium subscription
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
just visit us learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
if you are a parent or educator check
out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons additional
resources and classroom activities